on a assisté ces dernières heures à une
passe d'armes en règle en tri-françois
Blanchet chef du Bloc québécois et rouba
Gazal député de Québec solidaire et
aspirante comporte-parole de QS sujet de
cette improvisation mixte c'est quoi un
bon souvenir en 2023 ça commence donc
par le bloc qui ressort une vidéo de
Madame gazelle qui dit qu'elle vote NPD
au fédéral même si elle est
souverainiste et ça provoque donc ce
match de ping-pong dont voici un échange
alors au magasin répond à la diffusion
de la vidéo en disant interpellant
monsieur Blanchet le chef du Bloc
québécois vous n'êtes pas un pape qui
détermine qui est souverainiste et qu'il
n'est pas pour quelqu'un qui a dit qu'il
veut rassembler les indépendantistes
c'est mal parti et François Blanchet
retweet le tweet de Madame gazole faites
mieux madame Gazal vous votez pour le
NPD qui soutient sans condition les
libéraux centralisateurs
liberticide hostile au Québec et aux
travailleurs complices des pétrolières
et qui dit le Québec raciste les
militants de QS qui sont au bloc le
savent bien vos bagages se sert de son
temps de parole sur la motion sur le
référendum de 1995 hier pour renvoyer la
balle à Monsieur Blanchet
je trouve son attitude indigne d'un chef
de parti politique
c'est vraiment choquant monsieur le
Président de la part de quelqu'un qui
dit qu'il veut rassembler tous les
indépendantistes du Québec
comment est-ce qu'on peut rassembler
quand on s'attaque à des personnes comme
moi qui veulent que le mouvement
indépendantiste grandissent et
s'élargissent partout dans la population
ok donc
deux visions peut-être qui s'affrontent
enfin quand on les essais de les
caricaturer ou les définir un peu les le
Bloc québécois le Parti québécois
nationaliste le QS souverainiste mais
inclusif Jean-François puis je résume
Jean-François vous voyez ce débat là
comment entre les deux
je veux dire ça existe parce que Madame
Ghazal a dit dans son annonce en fin de
semaine que l'indépendance serait sa
priorité dans sa course au poste de
comportarole et ensuite dans 10 on parle
pas assez d'indépendance or dans cette
vidéo qui a été ressortie qui date de
tout à l'heure c'est en mars dernier
madame madame gazelle disait bien sûr
que je vois NPD pour fédéral et elle
disait qu'elle détestait au plus haut
point et je la cite le discours quand on
parle de la nation québécoise quand on
parle du Québec du pays de l'histoire
évidemment on dit pas comme ça mais on
parle aux gens qui étaient là disons au
début dans le temps de la Nouvelle
France là je caricature mais entre les
lignes c'est comme si on parle ça c'est
livré ok alors je déteste au plus haut
point et elle le dit une deuxième fois
tout le discours contient sur le Québec
la nation bon alors évidemment si t'es
pas de nationaliste pourquoi tu veux pas
faire l'indépendance du Québec et là la
question qui est posée c'est comment
est-ce que que quelqu'un pour qu'il
indépendance est une priorité si c'était
une de 12 choses importantes on dirait
bon ben dans ce cas là je peux voter NPD
ou fédéral parce que c'est pas si
important que ça l'indépendance mais à
partir du moment où tu dis c'est la
priorité pourquoi ne vote pas pour des
indépendantistes
Ottawa surtout que le NPD
contredit les positions de QS à
plusieurs égards par exemple que c'est
pour un rapport d'impôts unique le NPD
et compte QS voulaient aucune condition
pour les transferts en santé diagnostic
et pour qu'il y a plusieurs sujets sur
lesquels il y a une vraie
contradictionnaire donc Madame Gazal ne
répond pas à cette question là pourquoi
est-ce que des indépendantistes au
Québec n'appuient pas des
indépendantistes à Ottawa d'autant que
le bloc dans son congrès a fait une
contorsion pour rejeter une proposition
disant François en même temps et en même
temps son congrès du Bloc québécois là
il y avait personne qui veut être
solidaire c'était Pauline Marois c'était
pas le saint-pierre-flammondo
c'est sûr c'est sûr parce que parce que
Québec solidaire appuie le NPD
constamment au sol mais ils ont quand
même fait une motion pour dire ben on
accepte les gens on on comment ils l'ont
modifié en disant
on reconnaît les liens historiques avec
le PQ mais on est ouvert à tous et il y
a des militantes QS au bloc mais on sait
bien que il y a pas d'appui réel mais à
partir du moment la question qui est
posée à Madame gazelle c'est
comment une indépendanceise peut voter
pour un parti fédéraliste à Ottawa et sa
réponse c'est il est indigne que vous
attaquiez une fille de la loi 101 je
pense c'est pas la réponse à la question
qui est posée Dimitri vous trépignez
j'ai besoin de trépigner sur votre
chaise allez-y oui donc essentiellement
ce que Jean-François vient de faire
c'est de mettre Yves François Blanchet
au défi que lors de la prochaine
campagne électorale fédérale pendant 35
jours Yves François Blanchet aura la
même audace et conviction qu'a eu Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon c'est-à-dire que
pour pendant 35 jours Yves François
Blanchet ne va parler que de rien
d'autre que de l'indépendance du Québec
et sur ce débat si j'avais à choisir je
serai équipe
gazelle pourquoi parce que ce que Madame
Gazelle est en train de dire c'est
lors du prochain référendum
assurons-nous que l'argent est le vote
technique soit du bord du oui et j'étais
curieux j'étais curieux je suis allé
voir le site web du bloc et j'ai vu les
32 députés 32 hommes et femmes blancs et
blanches donc la diversité la vraie
diversité c'est à dire pas juste
quelqu'un qui habitait en Europe ou
césarien grand-père était italien la
diversité du point de vue minorité
visible n'existe pas au sein du caucus
du Bloc québécois donc défi lancé par
Jean-François à Yves François Blanchet
35 jours ne parlez que de rien d'autre
que de l'indépendance du Québec bonne
chance avec ça et je tiens à vous
rappeler
[Rires]
donc c'est moi alors donc c'est moi
alors qui qui met monsieur Blanchet au
défi d'avoir le même courage et les
mêmes convictions que Paul Sabri est-ce
que tu penses à noter je pense que ruban
Gazal devrait voter blanc dans ce cas-là
voyons en premier ces valeurs mais
madame gazelle notons le est né au Liban
et les venus au Canada et les maintenant
canadienne québécoises souverainiste
normal qu'une indépendance vote pour un
parti fédéraliste sans réalisateur je
vais vous je vais vous répondre à cette
question madame gazelle clairement et à
gauche
socialiste c'est le bloc le blog non non
je suis désolé Jean-François le vase
communicant au fédéral le vase
communicant d'électeurs
en anglais on dit
entre les conservateurs et le blogs OK
sur les pétrolières sur l'environnement
mais sur la culture canadienne c'est un
parti de centre gauche voyons
Jean-François Jean-François vous étiez
vous étiez je vous étiez à Québec
pendant 20-30 ans quand je courtisais
des gens comme Michel Gauthier Michel
Gaultier du Saguenay Lac Saint-Jean
n'était pas un gars de gauche quand je
courtisais des gens comme
les gens de gauche
le programme du bloc et de centre gauche
le toujours été voyant d'accord mais
Françoise est-ce qu'on peut voter NPD au
fédéral et être souverainiste
bah moi je peux vous dire par expérience
lorsque j'y étais au NPD de 2011 à 2015
premièrement j'ai croisé beaucoup de
souverainisses dans mon coq des gens qui
étaient de très québécois Pierre
nantaise
toutes les histoires qu'on a sorti sur
Alexandre boulesris puis c'est ici donc
bon Nicole Turmel les gens passent alors
il y avait un fort contingent du Québec
la faiblesse peut-être du NPD
présentement c'est qu'il y en ajuster
pour garder le fort du Québec et ça
c'est peut-être trop fort pour lui parce
que la force du nombre n'y est pas mais
effectivement il y a toute la question
gauche-droite et pour plusieurs
électeurs Québec solidaires ils se
retrouvent beaucoup plus dans les
potions néodémocrates Jean-François
raison par contre parce que on s'amuse
souvent à dire que le néo le NPD c'est
le faire valoir de libéraux mais je
regarde les votes à la chambre
[Musique]
j'aurais pu dire on devrait s'asseoir
toi et moi et se parler pour justement
enlever un peu de cette image là parce
que auteur on voit le NPD comme un parti
de gauche autant pour beaucoup de gens
le Bloc québécois c'est le petit cousin
ou le grand cousin dépendamment de sa
force électorale du moment du Parti
québécois on l'a jamais vraiment vu
ailleurs mais le grand gagnant dans tout
ça d'après moi c'est le Parti libéral du
Québec qui doit être su jouer à peu près
se sentir il y a peut-être un il y a
peut-être un leader qui parle qui se dit
Hey le danger des souveraineté sur
jamais été aussi fort grâce à qui Paul
Saint-Pierre Plamondon qui a réussi tout
seul comme un grand gars à faire réagir
la planète politique du Québec de cette
façon-là jusqu'à Ottawa en plus et si le
PLQ trouve le bon chef la bonne chef
effectivement
les libéraux vont remonter si les
libéraux peuvent se redéfinir et ne plus
être uniquement le parti des anglophones
mais de trouver une façon de reconnecter
et ça ça peut être une bonne façon de le
faire et je termine Sébastien en disant
au souverainisme moi ce qui me fascine
moi qui n'en suis pas une comment se
fait-il qu'à chaque fois qu'une petite
remontée il faut qu'il finisse par se
chicaner entre autres je ne comprends
pas
honnêtement
si vous voulez faire la souveraineté du
Québec unissez vos forces par été de
vous chicaner pour des pecs à dire pour
des picadés tout le temps à savoir
comment
BD honnêtement en quoi ça nous dérange
parce qu'elle a raison la souveraineté à
se Frot pas Ottawa Jean-François la
souveraine
à ce moment-là sincèrement ce qu'on
retient comme observateur c'est que les
pics réussissent et les souverainistes
plutôt réussissent toujours à centre
déchiré entre eux et ça moi je pense que
ça vous affaiblit et ça affaiblit le
pôle saint-pierre-amandon qui fait tout
ce qui peut pour raviver cette flamme là
et peut-être que Monsieur Blanchet en
fin de semaine il y aurait pu tendre la
main au Québec solidaire il n'en a eu
que pour le Parti québécois alors là il
récolte ce qu'il a semé Jean-François
justement moi je trouve qu'on tendu la
main en fin de semaine en refusant une
motion disant que c'était le PQ à 100%
ils ont ils ont ils ont travaillé pour
battre une résolution qui disait ça
justement pour laisser une petite place
aux gens de Cuesmes aux militants tu es
ce qui reste il y en a dans la région de
Québec en particulier mais on sait très
bien que aucun chef de QS aurait accepté
une invitation à venir au congrès du
blog j'aime j'aime
que ça se passe la prochaine fois et
c'est ce que je débat est-ce qu'il y a
un débat à l'intérieur de QS est-ce
qu'une Christine Labrie ou quelqu'un
d'autre va dire écoutez nous on pense
qu'on devrait être présent au bloc etc
ça serait une très très belle sortie de
cette crise là je suis d'accord avec
Michel que c'est c'est batailles là
entre souverainistes c'est pas ce que
c'est pas ce que l'abandon veut puis ça
ça aide pas ça aide pas je suis d'accord
je termine ça serait aussi à Yves
François Blanchet à le dire à le
verbaliser à remettre la balle dans le
camp de Québec solidaire absolument pas
adorer à la prochaine au prochain caucus
du blogs
il devrait s'appeler aujourd'hui il
devrait parler ou prendre un petit café
quelque chose pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI